hello everyone and welcome to today's
session one webinar simple steps to
publication quality western blots i am
jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more
visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
jordan thompson phd
product manager electrophoresis at
thermo fisher scientific
dr thompson you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone thank you for joining part
one of our webinar series titled simple
steps to publication quality western
blots
my name is jordan thompson and i'm a
product manager here at thermal fishery
scientific before becoming a product
manager i was an r d scientist and i was
performing western lots every day for
over the last 10 years
and i'm excited to share with you some
of the simple steps that i've learned
that i can help you improve and
transform your western blotting
experience
western blotting is one of the most
widely performed protein detection
applications
with an estimated five million western
blots performed globally each year
and typically western blotting is used
to visualize target proteins in a
complex protein mixture which could be a
cell lysate it could be used to study
protein protein interactions
or the effect of gene knockouts or gene
silencing or overexpression within cell
lines and it can also be used in a
number of ways to examine how an
external stimulus like a drug could
affect protein expression in downstream
pathways
even though western blotting is very
common and widely used there has been an
increase
in the concern recently over the
reproducibility and the quality of
western blotting data that's been
submitted to peer-reviewed journals
in 2014 the national institute of health
in the journal science and nature
organized a meeting with other
publishers and scientists on the topic
of reproducibility and transparency of
published scientific data
and from this collaboration there was a
new set of guidelines that was actually
developed for publishing within journals
and one particular area that the meeting
focused on was the concern over
image-based data
such as western bots
and they found that there
was a number of issues issues in the
reproducibility and rigor of research
findings that have been published
and so
based on these concerns on the
reproducibility and the quality of
western blotting data that was being
submitted to peer-reviewed journals
publications actually revised their
instructions for submitting
non-quantitative
and quantitative western blood data to
reflect some of the meetings conclusions
and recommended back best practices
within this webinar series
which has three parts we're going to
talk about some of the ways that you can
optimize your protocols in order to give
you the best
publication ready experiments
today we'll be focusing on part one
which we will be covering image
collection and presentation
primary antibody considerations and ways
that you can improve band resolution
through experimental design instead of
digital changes
so let's start with image collection and
presentation
these are some examples of image
manipulation techniques that have
actually shown up in publications
with number a you see there that there
are actually multiple blots that have
been spliced together to give the
impression of a single blot
when you're performing when you're
presenting your images for a publication
it's very important to actually include
the outline for separate blots even when
you're splicing them together into the
same image
and it's very common that a reviewer or
the journal may come back and ask you
for the raw images associated with those
blocks
and it can be really embarrassing
actually because i've seen it happen in
person before
when a splice bot was actually presented
in a talk and people commented it
during the question session
in b this would be a more typical
example of something that'd be common
which is oversaturation
this is typically done a lot of times on
housekeeping proteins where
you're trying to get a loading control
to look similar
when maybe actually there are
differences in the loading control or
differences in the load amount that
could be real and could be impacting
your actual conclusions
c is similar
where you'd be adjusting the contrast in
order to hide maybe unwanted bands
there's actually other ways to address
this maybe it's through optimizing your
blocking buffer which we're going to
cover in part two or your ecl substrate
which will also be in part two
or maybe it's changing the immunoassay
and the washing steps or the
concentration of your antibodies there
are other ways to handle this
that don't necessarily require
digital manipulation and then d is an
example of an image that's been
manipulated to remove bands and change
the contrast to specific bands within
the blot which is clearly just
manipulation
the typical guidelines that you may
encounter from a publication
would be to denote the splice points
with lines or outlines
when
different plots have been spliced
together to form the same image
when you are showing blots it's good to
actually show the molecular weight
markers if you can
and
as i said journals may actually
request that you submit the raw images
as well
if you're using digital tools
like photoshop
the contrast in your changing contrast
or brightness should be applied to all
of the images that are being shown
simultaneously and the whole image and
not just a part
it's good to avoid building figures in
powerpoint largely because powerpoint
exports at a lower gpi unless you
actually go in and change the settings
so we'd recommend photoshop or
illustrator so that you can submit
images that are 300 dpi or better
and in general
as you're developing your experiments
for your publication it's good to choose
two to three journals that you're
interested in submitting to and then
actually read through their guidelines
on this mission and look up similar
papers to the one the study that you'll
be publishing
so you can be aligned and you can
actually gather your experimental data
in the format that they're gonna want
for publication to save you time in the
end
um these are just general guidelines
it's really important to just to become
familiar with the guidelines from
different publications
um so that you can be aware of what's
required before you publish and what you
might be requested of from reviewers
so for part two we're going to talk
about primary antibody considerations
and
primary antibody is definitely the heart
of western blot detection
there's nothing more frustrating than a
primary antibody that doesn't work
correctly or doesn't identify your
actual protein and nothing worse than
when you try multiple primary antibodies
against an antigen and they continually
fail
it can be so frustrating 2012 an
independent lab
were actually unable to replicate the
results of 47 out of 53 tested cancer
research papers
antibody quality is definitely a key
focus and it's really important for us
here at thermo fisher scientific
it's really important when we're doing
western blotting that we actually
validate our primary antibodies
it's good to test numerous antibodies
against your target in the specific
application
for me as a scientist when i'm looking
for a new primary antibody i actually
look for publications that are using uh
specific antibodies against my antigen
hopefully in the same cell line or at
least a cell same cell type that i'm
working with
it's good to verify each lot of antibody
using positive and negative controls
if you're looking at overexpression
versus endogenous expression could
actually change your needs for antibody
sensitivity because an antibody
generated against an over expressing
clone might not work against endogenous
expression of a protein
and if you're using commercial
antibodies
journals are going to request the
supplier number the supplier the catalog
number and they may request the lot
number and species of origin and it's
always good to share the dilutions and
the protocols that you actually use when
you're doing western body
and for that reason it's important to
keep detailed records of the antibodies
in your western body procedure so that
you can include them in your publication
so that other research can benefit from
your hard work and we can continue to
grow the list of validated primary
antibodies
and i think an important consideration
here is to start with a trusted antibody
source
and here at thermo thermal fissure
scientific we take this very seriously
not only do we have uh trusted and
verified secondary antibodies and we
have hrp and alkaline phosphate
phosphatase conjugated antibodies
we also have uh fluorescent secondary
antibodies that can be used in
fluorescent multiplexing as well
and they're available in different
purity levels
and
one of the things that we strive for is
offering high quality and reliable
primary antibodies that are validated
and so
we actually have an antibody validation
program and we publish the results
actually on the web
for our antibody pages and you can find
the data right there looking at multiple
cell lines
different over expression
knock downs with the controls actually
built in to save you the time for having
to validate so that you can buy with
confidence and that you can know that
the antibodies are going to perform in
your application whether it's western
blotting ihc flow cytometry or whatever
research application you're going to use
it for that it's been verified against
now we get into the meat i feel like of
the presentation and this is improving
band resolution with experimental design
this one is near to my heart
and really the goal here is that
improving the resolution of a western
blot starts with improving uh starts
with your electrophoresis really starts
with your sample prep but it starts with
your gel and the initial separation
there's different considerations that
can actually be made
for ways that you can improve your
overall western blood and that includes
the buffer system the gel chemistry
the different well loading volumes and
well format and the gel percentage and
within western blotting even beyond this
is the transfer method the blocking
buffer your immunoassay and if you're
doing chemiluminescence your ecl
substrates
or your primary and your secondary
antibody concentrations every single one
of those steps can be optimized to give
you better performance of your western
blot and there are different levers that
can be pulled in order to tailor your
western blot for the protein that you're
studying
so often we think of western blotting as
a fixed method where you have a western
blotting protocol that you inherited
from your pi or from a postdoc or you
got from an sop
in the company that you joined
but really
there needs to be a shift in the
paradigm so that we tailor our western
blots to target the proteins that we're
studying because these different options
that are available really make for an
improved experimental outcome when
they're tailored for the specific
molecular weights and proteins being
studied
within this precast gels let's let's dig
into precast gels
and so within precast gels there's
different buffer systems
the first being continuous versus
discontinuous continuous buffer system
uses the same buffer in the gel and the
running buffer
a discontinuous buffer system which is
most commercially precast available gels
uses actually a different buffer in the
gel and the running buffer
there's different gel layers
usually at least two that create
different pore sizes that affect the
migration of the proteins through the
gel and different buffer compositions
and different ions within the gel and
the running buffer can significantly
change how proteins actually migrate and
the end
result of an electrophoretic brain
and electrophoresis using a discontinued
buffer system results in a concentration
of the sample
and a higher resolution performance gel
for the discontinuous buffer systems
thermal fissure actually has four
different systems that we have tris
glycine bistrous tris acetate and what's
not shown is tricine but we'll cover it
a little bit later
now the way that these different buffer
systems vary is actually in the ions
that they're made up of within the gel
and within the running buffer
um for tris glycine
and we'll we'll dig into each of these
in more depth but for juris glycine
within the running buffer the common ion
is tris
and it's actually
present in both the gel and the running
buffer
during the run your leading ion is
chloride your protein and your sds
complex is actually
in the center and it's followed by the
trailing ion glycine
and that creates the stack which as the
positive ions are rushing up these
negative ions go down and that's what
actually causes the proteins to compress
and resolve within their place within
the gel
[Music]
the operating ph of tris glycine is
higher it's more alkaline around 9.5
for this tris gel system the common ion
within the gel and the running buffer is
bistress
and the leading ion again is chloride
but in this case the trailing iron is
either mes or mops and that's actually
determined by your running buffer and
you have the option of choosing mes
which runs faster and causes a slight
decrease in your broad range molecular
weight range separation or mops which
runs a little bit slower but gives you
a slightly higher molecular weight range
for your separation
and on the right we have our tris
acetate gel system
and in this case
the leading ion is acetate followed by
the protein complex with sds which is
what's causing it to separate by
molecular weight and then tricene which
is the trailing ion
bistress and tris acetate gels were
developed to operate near or closer to a
neutral ph with bistrous operating ph of
7 and trace acetate and operating ph of
8.1 and we'll get a little bit more into
the details in the next few slides
so starting with tris glycine
in 1970
lamellae actually introduced a modified
version of the ornstein and davis buffer
system
to an electrophoresis that included the
use of sds or sodium dodecal sulfate and
this allowed denatured proteins to be
coated with sds and actually separate
through the gel towards the anode based
on their relative molecular weight
while this system was definitely proven
its worth over the years it actually
suffers from several issues due to the
higher
ph of the buffer
and so even though it's the most widely
used
gel chemistry for separating proteins
the higher alkaline operating ph
may actually cause some band distortion
loss of resolution artifacts in the
bands due to protein degradation or
alteration during the gel run
some of the chemical alterations that
could be experienced is dm deamination
hydrolysis alkylation of proteins due to
the high ph of the resolving gel
and also potentially re-oxidation of the
disulfide bonds in the cysteines within
the proteins
due to the redox state of the gel not
being consistent
that said
we do have high performing novak's tris
glycine gels for
[Music]
for anyone who
would prefer the lamellae based system
these gels are very high performance
with great band resolution and sharpness
they also have the wedge well format
which allows for easier loading of up to
60 microliters per sample
and it's not only that you can load more
with the wedge ball but it's actually
because the wall is larger it's easier
to load to and easier to remove the comb
and these gels are flexible they can be
used either
an sds page or native page because the
gels themselves don't actually contain
sds
and on the right we have an example of
in vitrogen novak's four to twenty
percent gels tris glycine gels run in
comparison to bio-rad's tgx four to
twenty percent tris glycine jealous
one of the distinctions that you can see
with the tris glycine gel chemistry is
actually that as a gel runs from the top
as samples run from the top to the
bottom
there's sometimes a widening in the
width of the bands which you can see
very much here in the biored shell
one of the differences that we often see
between
the novxtra slicing gels and biored tgx
so sometimes there can be degradation
products that show up between
um for purified proteins so lanes three
to eight here are purified proteins and
you can see that there are extra bands
showing up in lane 4
which aren't present in the novx gel so
those are some of the considerations
that you would want to make when you're
looking into which precast tris glycine
gel
is best for your experiment
our novak's gels or novex glycine gels
don't have the same level of smiling or
distortion in the bands as just from
other suppliers
and so
here again showing um gels novak's wedge
vultures glycine gels in comparison to a
biorad tgx gel
and this is with protein ladders e coli
lysate and purified protein again
and one of the things that we look for
when we talk about band quality or
performance of a gel
is the migration of specific proteins to
make sure that it's going to be
reproducible over time as the gel ages
over the whole shelf life of the gel
we look at straightness so from the left
to right
is the
band migration straight across the whole
gel or does it have a smiling effect
that would be indicative of the gel
performance failing
and then we also look at curvature and
we look to make sure that the bands on
the outside of the gel aren't exhibiting
significant curvature whereas they're
not straight which will contribute to
the smiling and decrease the performance
of the overall gel run and when you
transfer a gel like this it'll
definitely show up in the transfer as
well making it harder to do the
downstream detection
[Music]
our novak's tris glycine gels also come
with the wedge well format and so wedge
well just showing a picture here on the
right
it's a wedge-shaped comb that creates a
larger well
and these larger wells can hold up to 60
microliters per well so it's a larger
sample well volume and it's actually
easier to load and the combs are
actually easier to remove as well
which is nicer than some gels which are
difficult to pull a comb out
these gel still are high performance and
don't have any additional
quality or performance issues associated
with them
one of the nice things about the
wedgewell format is not just increasing
is that you can actually load more
sample volume without risk of spillover
so when you have a dilute sample that
you need to load more sample of and this
is just showing a fluorescent ladder
that's been loaded at 10 to 60
microliters another are novak's wedge
welter slicing gels or a competitor gel
and you can see that as you increase the
volume of the fluorescent ladder the
wedge ball gel
is able to accommodate all of it but in
the competitor gel as you do that
spillover is observed
and when you have dilute samples it can
be really frustrating to not be able to
load as much samples you actually need
to load in order to get a good result
in your experiment so instead of having
to restart your whole experiment to get
a higher concentration lysate so you can
load in the gel we have our wedge ball
gels that allow you to load more sample
and
not have to pursue restarting the
experiment
now
to solve the problem that was
encountered with tris glycine gels in
1996
novak's um which actually became
uh eventually life technologies and was
acquired by thermo fishery scientific
novak's introduced the new page line of
bistrous gels including bistrous and
trisostate actually the bistrist gel
chemistry shown on this page
has an operating ph of six point or has
a buffering system with a ph of 6.4
and that causes it to have a neutral ph
when a neutral operating ph which
overcomes the shortcomings of the
traditional lamellae system
and it leads to a substantial reduction
in the rate of gel matrix hydrolysis
which not only minimizes protein
degradation and chemical modification
but also substantially improves shelf
life
um these gels both are new page bistress
and our volt bistress plus have a 16
month shelf life to ensure that they're
not going to expire when you're running
experiments
because the operating ph for the
bistrous system is 7 it greatly reduces
unwanted protein modifications during a
gel run
also unlike lamellae gels
or tris glycine gels new page bistress
gels
can actually be stored at room
temperature
which will save on refrigerator space so
it's not just a 16 month shelf life but
it's actually 16 months at room
temperature as well
and new page samples are heated at 70
degrees for 10 minutes instead of being
boiled and the combination of a higher
starting ph
which the new page sample buffer which
also uses tris has been adjusted to 8.3
so the combination of a higher starting
ph and a lower heating temperature
actually significantly reduces protein
bond cleavage while at the same time
still reducing the cysteine disulfide
bonds
like you would want
and so our bistrous gels are an
improvement on the traditional lamellae
tris glycine gels and offer
a number of different
advantages over the tris glycine system
and actually following the release of
new page
in
2012 life technology actually introduced
the bolt bistrous plus gels
and these are a modification of the
standard bistrus chemistry and actually
an improvement on it
it still has the neutral ph which
preserves sample integrity and gives
these gels the long 16 month shelf life
but the modification of the chemistry
actually allows these gels to be the
fastest bistrous gels on the market
while maintaining band quality
um
these gels also have the wedge well
feature that allows for more samples to
be loaded
and
an easier fashion than the standard
format gels and with the bolt bistress
gels you can actually run your proteins
run your experiment your electrophoresis
and as fast as 20 to 24 minutes
and as a scientist these were my go-to
gels i would use in vitrogen bolt
bistrous plus four to twelve percent
gels
because they ran fast and i could get my
experiment done quickly and easily with
the wedge well if i did have a dilute
sample i could load the extra volume
that i needed in order to get the
experiment completed
and on the right here um what's being
shown is a bull mistress plus gel in
comparison to a bio-rad tgx
and these are different purified
proteins in comparison to the magic mark
protein standard and one of the things
you can see is that for purified
proteins you'd expect to see maybe a
single or two bands um
but in some of these in one in the blood
on the right you can see that there are
extra protein bands showing up which
would be indicative of degradation
products
and so that comes back to the
combination of the neutral ph of the
bistrous gel chemistry and also the
reduced
sample heating requirements that cause
an improved outcome in your experimental
result
now the other two chemistries that we
have
are for specialized
applications so tris acetate gels are
actually for studying higher molecular
weight proteins
um
whereas tris glycine and bistrus just
showing the migration chart here
um trace glycine bistress would give you
a
separation of up to about 250
kilodollars tristacetate can go up to
500 kilometers which means that you're
going to get better
results with a tris acetate gel if
you're studying higher molecular weight
proteins
and using our protocols which have been
adapted for tris acetate
for high molecular weight transfers
so tris acetate gives you optimal
separation of higher molecular weight
proteins
it also because it has the more neutral
ph it preserves the protein sample
integrity just like the new page bistris
gel chemistry
and it has excellent transfer of higher
molecular weight proteins which can be
extremely difficult to study
because it might be that your
cells are producing plenty of your
higher molecular weight protein that you
want to study
but your actual gel system isn't
designed to be able to accommodate that
and so on the right here we have the new
page three to eight percent tris acetate
miniatures looking at egfr
190 kilodoms
in it with a dilution curve in
comparison to the same sample ram
on a novx four to twenty percentage
glycine gel
for both the protein this is visible but
with the three to eight percent acetate
miniature it's far more abundant and far
more sensitive which is going to give
you potentially a better result in your
downstream applications
and lastly
the tricene gel chemistry is actually
for studying lower molecular weight
proteins
the advantages of tricing gels over tris
glycine gels is increased resolution of
proteins as small as 2.5 kilowatts so
you have small proteins that you're
studying where you need them to still
resolve and separate
a tricene gel
could be right for you
has improved
compatibility with direct protein
sequencing applications after
transferring to pvf membranes
it has minimized protein modifications
due to a lower ph of the tricep
buffering system in comparison to that
alkaline tris glycine and it has
minimized blow through of protein during
protein transfer which is always a risk
when you're looking at lower molecular
weight proteins we've optimized the
protocols for tricine gels in order to
give you the best results for lower
molecular weight proteins
and the migration chart is a little bit
difficult to see here
but these are the different percentages
of tricia gels with 10 and 16
and 10 to 20 percent and one of the
things that i want to highlight is down
here
you can really see that with a 10 to 20
percent wide range you can get down to
2.5 kilo dalton and then you can even
separate out six or 14 kilo dalton
proteins and on the right there what it
really shows is that with the novak 16
tricying gel you can clearly see the
separation between the 19 and the 17
kilodalton bands of cleave cast phase 3
whereas with biorad's tgx gels those
bands are stacked on top of each other
because that gel is not formulated to
resolve those proteins that are that
small not close together
so really when it comes to gel chemistry
it's best to tailor your gel chemistry
actually to the protein that you're
studying
and so if you're looking at a broad
range of molecular weights it's tris
glycine or bistress these are your
everyday precast gels that you use in
your experiments
but if you're looking for higher
molecular weight proteins or really
small molecular weight proteins that are
very close together it's trisocity and
tricing gels respectively
um bistrous gels one of the other
advantages of them is that there are two
different running buffers
mops buffer
and mes buffer
mes buffer runs faster than mops so for
your everyday runs you're going to get
your experiment done faster but if you
do need a slower run with slightly
increased molecular weight range you can
swap out mop's buffer and it gives you
another way to fine-tune and optimize
your experiment um for what you need on
the day when you're doing it and the
protein that you're studying
and another consideration with precast
gels or protein gels used in
electrophoresis is which gel percentage
that you use
and i think all western blot users are
very familiar with this but you use a
lower percentage gel to resolve larger
molecular weight proteins
um that means that the pores are going
to be bigger so the larger proteins can
migrate through it faster
and will show up lower or farther into
the gel
if you use a higher percentage
acrylamide gel
you can resolve smaller molecular weight
proteins
[Music]
molecules in general your protein or
your target of interest should migrate
at least
into the gel
um should migrate 70 of the length of
gel for best resolution really this is
just indicating that you want to get
good separation within your lysates or
your
sample so you can make sure that you're
separating out all the bands of interest
and if you're trying to look at a wider
molecular weight of proteins within a
mixture within a cell lysate gradient
gels are a great choice
gradient gels allow you to have a larger
or broader molecular weight range within
a single gel
which means that you can look at more
proteins of interest within the same
block
and so for improving your resolution
with the right gels and buffer system
and not using digital tools the
recommendations are consider to consider
the buffer system used to choose the
appropriate geochemistry for the target
molecular weight that you're actually
studying
to choose the gel chemistry that
decreases protein degradation
to consider wedge well format gels to
reduce band distortion to allow you to
load more sample if you have dilute
samples and have easier sample loading
and also to tailor the acrylamide
percentage or to choose a gradient gel
in order to improve resolution and be
able to see your targets of interest all
within the same block
that concludes part one of today's
webinar
um
part two and part three are upcoming but
today what we covered was image
collection and presentation
primary antibody considerations
improving band resolution and
experimental design
without using digital manipulation
all webinars will be recorded and
emailed to you after the session
um
and we definitely like to invite you to
come back and tune in for part two which
will be looking at improving background
with experimental design
improving detection of low abundance
proteins
or part three
improving reproducibility and special
conditions considerations for
quantitative western blots
with that i'd like to thank you
and also
put a plug in here for our western body
and education system this is a great
resource
you can access our educational resource
materials and tips to help you with
every aspect of your western blotting
workflow you can watch how-to videos to
discover new ways to do western body get
quick tips to improve your western blot
and data and watch webinars like this
one to receive first-hand knowledge of
the latest technologies for western body
we also have recipes for buffer stock
solution just general western bot
protocols you can see the link down here
below i encourage you to check it out
with that thank you for your attention
your time today and i'd be happy to take
any questions that you have
thank you dr thompson for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for okay let's get
started our first question
i have been using the four to three
percent gradient bolt bistress gel but
run into the issue of one
first too well show smiley bands two
wells are close to one another and hard
to separate the bands for analysis
thanks jennifer thanks for the question
um so we do i think it's the four to
twelve percent gradient both mistress
gels that we sell
um for smiling bands one thing that you
could do for optimizing your run would
be to consider which running buffer that
you're using
uh typically with our precast gels
that's actually one of the things with
qc and that goes into our cova is
adjusting for
the band migration the straightness and
the curvature and so if you are seeing
smiley bands
make sure that you are loading an equal
load amount across the whole gel for
your sample buffer so skipping a lane
could potentially actually impact your
electrophoresis run or your
electrophoretic run so we would
recommend loading 1x sample buffer with
reducing engine in that lane um if you
are still seeing smiling bands you could
adjust the sample loads um sample load
volume and lysate load or protein mode
should be equivalent across the whole
gel
in order to again ensure the same
electrophoretic mobility across all the
legs
and then with the
wells being close to one another and
hard to separate the bands for analysis
we do offer multiple comb types and so
if you for our mini gels we offer 10 12
15 and 17 well gels and if you are
struggling with the bands being too
close to each other i would recommend
switching to our sherlock tandem
midi gel tank and our midi precast gels
or our wide format shells which are
available in 12 plus two which have very
large wells
20 well and 26 well formats
thank you for the question
thank you dr thompson our next question
any special considerations for using
nanobodies as primary antibodies
thanks that's a really interesting
question so
uh nanobodies
i believe were discovered in llamas and
alpacas
and they actually only have the anagen
binding heavy chain domain and not the
light variable chain so for an
experimental condition they're likely to
have less cross reactivity with other
antibodies
you for
your actual experimental design i'd say
um stay tuned for part two and the
considerations around your substrate
your detection method and your blocker
because that could be really important
for tailoring that i can imagine for
publications you would definitely want
to research that with the journal that
you're looking at to ensure that
you provide all the right information
you capture the right information when
you go to publish within antibodies
another consideration with nanobodies as
the primary antibodies would be
developing the experiment if you're
using a secondary antibody or just a
single nanobody
and the different
readouts and controls that you would
need to build into that
thank you dr thompson
our next question
do you think that running gels in the
cold and low voltage could reduce
smiling bands
so that's very common and actually that
was something that we did in grad school
where we did our runs at a lower voltage
and in the colt
and
that is very typical if you're doing a
gel that you poured yourself like the
traditional tris bison chemistry gels
when you're using a precast gel uh
there's actually
a lot of research that's gone into
optimizing the protocols and sometimes
actually reducing the voltage
can negatively impact your run so one of
the things i've really been impressed by
at joining
thermal fissure and seeing the
development of these precast gels and
the product development of
electrophoresis or electrophoresis
products is how much rigor goes into it
and so um
when a protocol recommends 200 volts for
20 to 24 minutes you can actually have
confidence that you're gonna get the
best results and that's actually what
the cfa is listed on
um one condition or one consideration
for potentially using the cold room we
do have the xl4 which can run four midi
gels at a time and when you're running
multiple midi gels which require greater
current greater power
it could potentially heat up and so that
would be one consideration for
potentially wanting to move that into
the cold room or chill your buffer in
order to mitigate that so as long as
your gel is not significantly heating up
i don't think that your run or your
performance will be impacted if you're
using our premium precast gels
thank you dr thompson the next question
how does the reducing agent change the
sample run
so the reducing agents are added to your
samples in order to
break down disulfide bonds and so that's
a vital part of the sds page
application and so without the reducing
agent
you won't be able to break those so
proteins won't necessarily migrate how
they're supposed to
so you definitely want to add the
reducing agent there's different types
um our reducing agent that we sell
uses dtt
we have seen a difference in the
performance between using gtt versus bme
which is another common one
which is why our products use dtt
because it actually gives better
performance and a better run overall
all right thanks again dr thompson our
next question
i want to detect a 380 kilo dalton
protein however i have only eight
percent bistros gel in my lab at the
time is it possible to overrun a gel in
mob's buffer system to allow the 380
kilodalton protein to enter the gel and
push forth small molecular weight
proteins from the bottom of the gel for
example zero to thirty kilo dalton for
qualitative analysis
that's a really interesting question
um
tritacetate gels would definitely be
best suited for this type of application
with three to eighty with the 380
kilodalton protein that said if you are
limited to only a bistrous gel an eight
percent bistrous you could try running
it longer as you suggested and that will
allow the protein to migrate further
into the gel in general we do recommend
that you allow the gel or the protein of
interest to migrate 20 to 30 into the
gel
so that it will transfer well
i would imagine that you would need to
consider your transfer
conditions for this and so i'd recommend
reading the user guide one of the things
that can typically be done for
transferring higher molecular weight
proteins would be an ethanol wash of the
gel
and that's going to differ depending on
the transfer system that you use so
definitely check the user guide
but those would be the different
considerations that you would want
in general higher molecular weight
proteins are really going to benefit
benefit from the tris acetate gel
chemistry and the wet transfer protocols
that have been designed and optimized
for it
great thank you again dr thompson our
next question here does the eyebrite
adjust images when they are captured
um so
the eyebrite when it initially does the
capture
does show you the image with brightness
and contrast which you can turn off in
the settings
um one of the things to so when eyebrite
does the band intensity analysis
it actually uses the raw image for that
and so
um if you're using an eyebrite which is
our the imager that we sell for our
western workflow um
when you're going to export your data i
would recommend exporting for
publication so you have your nice
brightness contrast adjusted image but
also the raw data file which will be
available right there and then if you're
doing any type of brightness contrast
adjustments on multiple images you can
do all of this simultaneously or if
you're using offline software for your
densitometry analysis
you could use the raw data file
thank you again dr thompson
our next question is there anything that
you have learned while developing
western blotting products that you wish
you had known when you first started
performing them
yeah so
prior to coming to thermal pressure i
was in grad school and we poured our own
gels
and our actual western blotting protocol
was about two and a half hours for a run
because we did run it up in the cold
room at a reduced voltage primarily
because we were poor in our own gels and
then we would typically do an overnight
or if it was the same day transfer it'd
be three hours so one of the things i
really wish i had known is about the eye
western workflow and the bolt gels
especially because you can run and
transfer a gel if you're using the ibot2
in under 40 minutes and it makes it
really easy to do i think the other
thing that i really wish that i had
known was about our midi gel uh precast
drills and tanks we actually had an
outdated system that was very
expensive for us to purchase
and it took weeks to even cast the gels
in that system and if i had known that
there was a
readily available midi gel system that
we can purchase for a lot less than what
we actually spent um i would have
happily done so
and we could have even purchased the
midi gel empty cassettes and cast our
own gels if we wanted to save cost
but by purchasing the precast shelves we
could have saved weeks worth of
optimizing and trying to repeat
experiments in order to get a published
publishable result especially since we
were using in vivo samples
great thank you again dr thompson our
next question here
any thoughts on using western blot
imagers versus a classic film developer
do imagers have high enough resolution
and sensitivity for publication
thank you really interesting question um
so we have done a number of application
notes that are
and
relevant
on this i mean one of the considerations
when i actually started out in grad
school we were using the classic film
developer where you go into the dark
room and you process everything
um
so a lot has changed in terms of the ecl
substrates that are available
and at thermal fissure
we have
substrates that are extremely sensitive
like our super signal ato
and they can definitely improve the
sensitivity and the resolution
when you're doing chemiluminescence now
our eyebrite's actually
developed and one of the things we
benchmarked against are the classic film
development in order to ensure that you
are going to get the best
experience when you're using our imager
and i think you can't really beat the
ease of use that it comes with using a
western blot imager where you can easily
get multiple captures versus trying to
develop film where you have to do
everyone separate or stack multiple
films and suffer quality loss and then
process them one by one in order to get
your result which can be very
challenging
all right thank you again dr thompson
our next question here considering that
an antibody is a protein is it possible
to detect it using the western blot
technique or which technique do you
recommend
uh it's definitely possible um
so when you're doing scs page the
protein is going to be denatured and so
it'll run
so as long as you have the right
antibodies in order to detect it you
should be able to pick it up
um
all right great thanks again
the next question
what is the advanced verification that
can sometimes be seen on antibodies on
the website
so on
thermofisher.com when you're searching
for a primary antibody
um there will sometimes be a check mark
that says advanced verification next to
it i actually really like this function
it's so frustrating trying to find good
and well working primary antibodies when
you double click on that it'll actually
take you to specific data that's been
generated to show that that antibody is
specific
which i kind of mentioned in the talk so
um when you click on the advanced
verification it'll actually show you the
experiments that were conducted either
to knock down the protein or to look at
it in different cell lines in order to
confirm that the antibody signal is
actually specific
and typically it'll show multiple
applications that the antibodies been
approved for so you might see western
body and ihc and so really what it does
is it gives you confidence that when you
go to purchase an antibody
you can know that it's actually going to
be specific for the antigen and work
correctly in your application
all right thank you again dr thompson
our next question
are there any significant differences
between precast gels and pour your own
gels
so the differences between precast gels
and pour your own
besides ease of use so precast gels
having them ready to go with a
significantly longer shelf life
um and being fully optimized for the
different electrophoretic tanks and
transfer apparatus
one of the things is that we use premium
great ingredients when we're casting our
precast gels we also have proprietary
gel chemistry so each of the gel
chemistries that i talked about today
aren't necessarily available in pour
your own
solutions
and so that's going to result in a
significant difference in the
performance of your actual gel run
and when we're casting these gels we do
it in an extremely controlled process
and all the gels are q seed afterwards
so that you can be
assured that they're going to be high
performing over the whole shelf life
that we guarantee them for
and one of the really nice things i mean
one of the challenging things with pour
your own gels is the short shelf life so
typically you're casting the gel and
using it the next day or certainly
within a week
but being able to have a bistress gel
that can be stored at room temperature
on a shelf for up to 16 months
is amazing you can savor refrigerator
space and you can save the time you can
probably actually run and transfer your
gel on the time that it would take to
just cast to pour your own gel
great thank you again dr thompson our
next question here
what could be the reason of seeing
negative bands apart from my bands is it
a gel or a blocking issue
so typically that would be something
with the amino acid
where and where we are going to cover
that in part two but optimizing your
blocking buffer can give you a
significantly different result um with
something like negative bands showing up
in a western block
um it could
so i i would just start there and you
might want to try multiple blocking
buffers in order to improve that result
um one other thing that can cause
negative bands would be depending on if
you're doing fluorescence or
chemiluminescence if there is something
blocking for instance if you have an ecl
substrate that's creating light
for your chemiluminescence and there is
something blocking um like perhaps
you're not using enough ecl substrate so
your antibody actually you get some
burnout that'll actually create a
negative band so if you're seeing
negative bands show up after you start
your detection with your
chemiluminescence substrate that i would
actually recommend increasing the amount
of substrate that you're using because
too little will actually increase
burnout or optimizing your antibody
concentrations and your immunoassay to
decrease them because you're actually
producing too much signal
thank you dr thompson looks like we have
time for one more question
let's see
how to improve or optimize the
polyclonal antibody
so in my experiments i haven't seen a
significant difference between polyconal
or monoclonal antibodies one of the
considerations though would be since
you're using both a primary and a
secondary antibody is that maybe it's
your secondary antibody that actually
needs to be optimized
in addition to that blocking buffer can
actually have an impact too
so
it might not be the primary antibody the
polyclonal antibody that needs to be
optimized it might be some of the other
reagents within your amino acid
that could be contributing to whatever
difficulty that you've been having
so i think it's just important to
consider each step
and how you can optimize it in order to
get the best results but in general we
see
equivalent results with our monoclonals
versus our polyconals at least in my
experience
thank you dr thompson do you have any
final comments for our audience before
we wrap up
i just want to say thank you um we have
a number of questions still in the chat
so we'll follow up by email
and address all of those but we
appreciate your time and your attention
and thank you again
well thank you again dr jordan thompson
for your time today we would also like
to thank labrutz and our sponsor thermo
fisher scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye